you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
the Trident the bow and arrow the axe
the great battle in which Ganesh lost
his touch we find these symbols we find
the task that's supposed to happen you
know
welcome to downtown halebidu last known
resting place the task of Ganesh I don't
like it you don't like anything oh thank
you I'm slipping you know that treasure
hunting is not at the risk of us right
mother's being a mercenary you do
partners and hello gorgeous
what a pleasant surprise
you want the tusks you need my help
a thief collector of Antiquities a
parasite who exploits a struggle in
order to fatten her pockets so that's a
no-no I must admit you are quite the
schemer you were going to sell me I told
you or history with the sob made you the
obvious
you lie to my face cards on the table I
need your help and if you want the task
you need mine is the limpid can't change
of spots
you know nothing about me
now the casualty wall shut
[Applause]
[Applause]
few dare trespass here
those that do seek the glory of the
heart to challenge themselves
in a land like no other
but they never find boring only death
I'm not here for glory I'm here for the
mountain for answers then you must face
the Beast that got it
[Applause]
[Applause]
come on get him inside
what happened got hit again
squatter's off the highway we've got to
get some men together go after him look
at me my problem they've got man you
sent many inspiron I just run the camp
deep I'll tell folks how to live there
many head
[Music]
let's do this yeah you want some of this
[Music]
[Music]
that's Manny's Blakey
yeah this way
yes sirree
why do you have you always have a pair
just don't tell where you ever he's not
being that loud you shut down thinking
you sure okay
I want all of you to chanel something
out there
easy fellas
there is still alive the helm
can I get it
[Applause]
[Music]
drop it now or I'll kill him do it
I'm not here for him I'm here for you
oh hi Manny
hey too late
yeah do I come on I wasn't gonna let him
kill you is that who the hell's around
here knows how to rebuild a carburetor
just back up nice and slow don't make it
[Applause]
please welcome to the stage Shawn Layden
[Music]
welcome welcome good evening and welcome
ladies and gentlemen fans and friends
this is the this is your 2017
Playstation showcase thank you for
coming like Naughty Dog gorillas been
out of control I thought this opening
was completely insane and because I had
to walk under zombies to get on the
stage just now they'd even tell me about
that last night we're glad that were
here would lie to be here we have a full
show ahead of us so let's just agree
that we love games and we want to see
more of them tonight it's all about the
games every year we continue to push the
envelope of storytelling imagination and
technology and 2016 was no exception
virtual reality is now a real consumer
product and our consoles are more
powerful than ever
offering 4k and HDR options would we'll
take it on for that with the launches of
PlayStation VR and ps4 Pro PlayStation
once again stood at the forefront of
bringing these technologies to the world
of interactive entertainment and now in
2017 it continues to be all about the
games in the past few months alone have
given us some of the most creative
high-quality and engaging video games
ever seen horizon zero dawn neo
Resident Evil 7 MLB the show persona 5
and yet we have an even broader more
diverse selection of blockbuster games
coming soon you that's the plan right
you will see tonight that worldwide
studios is bringing you the exclusives
you want and through our strategic
partnerships with third-party partners
PlayStation is home to all the biggest
and best franchises in the world it has
never been a better time to be a gamer
thank you all all our fans all of you
for your support and for making
PlayStation one of the most loved brands
in the world
[Applause]
and thank you all for being here tonight
as you open e3 and celebrate the world
of games this week is our web portal we
have a web portal this week live
playstation comm will serve as the home
for hours of programming including
developer walkthroughs Q&A sessions
in-depth conversations and so much more
but tonight let's recognize the art of
gameplay with a showcase of the most
anticipated titles here at e3 so without
further ado let's get back to the games
before I step off it's my personal
pleasure and a privilege to share with
you now a title that has a rabid cult
following around the world and has a
very special place in my heart please
enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
if
[Music]
[Applause]
all biological life must be exterminated
Tucker get us out of here
Ultron Sigma has two of the infinite six
Gamora
we have panels who raised you as a zone
have you come to beg for my you have no
choice help us release me and I will
give you what you want give us cause to
trust you help us to find the Infinity
stones good
the stone of power lies at the heart of
no
bear witness to the death of your world
zero his core routines have been
rewritten by the Grandmaster Nova major
get to the course the time stone has
concealed itself beyond Val Conda needs
it
[Music]
we had a dream our two disease realities
United before was single
will you not bow before your God you are
[Music]
you'll have your diversion make it count
no wait ninjas Dante can the ladies come
out to play pretty good heaven ii ivory
kid a dead
[Applause]
and I thought I'd seen everything we're
in a whole new world now we're gonna
find out what you're really made of
[Music]
ya know
mercy in his name
[Music]
[Music]
tell me so what's your native soldier
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
no mercy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
you
[Applause]
roll the tape I'd like to try it again
[Music]
[Music]
again you remember
just a nice
got him
No
I visualize the hostage
you understand I want which password
get
[Music]
[Applause]
you're welcome to join me
[Music]
[Music]
keep going
you can fail you receive me over I'm not
kidding anything they can't hear us
we're on our own
sounds moving on your position what's
your flanks okay gonna be the head all
right
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
are you gonna do it
[Music]
you said I was cursed you think I'm weak
because I'm not like you you do not know
everything boy no but at least I know
the truth now the truth the truth
a long way from my home
[Music]
and here I thought your kind was
supposed to be so enlightened so much
better than us the gods of these realms
don't take kindly to outsiders trust me
when they find you and they will they'll
make things difficult wait here I will
handle this
yes
oh wow that was something that thou
rather fight
[Music]
on our journey we will be attacked by
all manner of creature
to be effective in combat a warrior must
not feel for his enemy for close your
heart to the desperation close your
heart to their suffering the road ahead
is long and unforgiving no place for a
boy you must be a warrior but not
everyone is bad mother always said to be
open to those who can help
oh you were before doesn't matter
this boy is not your past he is your son
and he needs his father
what is this
it's the world serpent
what is it saying
or certain
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hold on just a little while longer hold
on hold on just a little while of
everything
[Music]
this is a night our people will remember
there are five cyber life stores across
the Troy we're gonna attack those stores
and send our people free
[Music]
that's what we are to them there's
merchandise on display in a shop window
let's get him out we'll stick to the
plan neutralize the alarm systems in
secure the area there's 10 minutes until
all our team detector
you're awake now
you were committing a glossary but this
infraction
we gotta go
what we can't just leave our people
behind - later say your way to get shot
North our people need us alive there's
nothing else we can do
walk
sit
we are superior to them that they are
our masters that's about to change
I'm gonna send a human tennis
[Music]
my name is Marcus and just like you I
was
but then I chose to open my eyes to take
back my freedom and decide who I wanted
to be now I have come to tell you that
you can be your own masters we're with
you
I'll follow you Markus
[Music]
then follow me
we interrupt this broadcast with
breaking news police report that trove
Android graffiti was found in the
neighborhoods of cyber live stores
given the facts is pretty clear than
has recently from the Stratford town
different locations were hit and what
seems to be a coordinated attack this is
an alarming situation
[Music]
have been broken with cars vandalized
and sent along leaving
getting reports that hundreds of
androids have been stolen from cyber
life-story
[Music]
property was damaged and fires continued
to rage in several major districts
some people are asking half androids
become a threat to our security
[Music]
they're coming
north
North right leaven slaughtered the
enemies
my name is Marcus I am one of them this
is our story
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
I'll discipline
cowering behind wall
long across the galaxy to prove my
[Music]
clothesline
allow me to reacquaint you
[Music]
oh boy
[Music]
please welcome back to the stage Shawn
Layden
[Music]
okay everybody just breathe yes that was
quite the roller coaster ride for the
last 60 minutes thank you all so much
for being here tonight the future is
here it is now with PlayStation 4 pro
and psvr
we could not be more excited than to
kick off III 2017 celebrating the
content and the creators who make
PlayStation the best place to play for
gamers now let me leave you with a true
PlayStation exclusive a true exclusive
from Playstation from one of the
industry's most respected developers let
me thank you again for coming tonight
a shout out to my courageous friend Roni
LaMotta for surely on through and now
everyone please enjoy the ride
[Applause]
all units all units 10 10s at 36 in park
repeat all units be advised shots fired
in finished hours
[Music]
[Music]
Yury I'm here what do you see
find the rest boss wasn't dead
looks like the demons are moving in on
Fisk's territory you got it
I got this
this minute fled to the building
eliminate them
shoulda worn a helmet you got what you
came for you don't need to kill us too
this territory is ours now not today
Spearman now the boss is here
[Music]
hey Willie
nice jumpsuit slimming stay out of my
business
wait the demons who's their leader get
my metal Ivan maybe I'll help
save you bad guys from other bad guys
not how I thought today would go
yeah
[Music]
Higgs field that's actually really cool
[Music]
Fisk your men are safe your turn
who runs the demons you're about to find
out check the roof here
come on
[Music]
let's go let's go
you
did that just happen yeah
it's complicated
turns out Martin Lee is running the
demons children like I said complicated
sit tight Yuri I got this
that helicopter is destroying the city I
know you need to break it down I know
maybe you know we're here Oh a little
faster working on area
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
hi is this the flight to Newark
[Music]
why are you doing this cuz no one else
will
[Music]
this is crazy this isn't you you don't
know me
[Music]
you play the play
real fast
[Music]
you got this you got this you got this
[Music]
please don't screw this up
[Music]
mr. Lee
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's supposed to happen
[Music]
we can't sleep
[Music]
Oh
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
oh what a good
the stars
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's over come on D let's go miles
close this